[Music]
in victoria's
reveal news submitted by chinese
barbecue
victoria's secret just cast its first
transgender model
are you even in the frame i just want to
stretch my legs a little bit but i'm in
the video oh
all right so this is victoria's secret's
first
openly transgender model named valentina
oh she's
gorgeous god damn she's hot beautiful
cheekbones are nuts
yeah goddamn so she's brazilian
that's why there it is it's gonna be
brazilian or time for me i'm kind of mad
because i thought asians made the best
uh transgender women
but i feel like they win brazilians just
because no i thought asians
were the number one that's why i thought
yeah thai people were like hands down
the best
before i saw her i was like she's gonna
be thai but i was wrong yep no but i'm
saying like so valentina
won it for all brazilians as best
transgender yeah they took it from us
yeah yeah okay yep so
she has so she's 23 years old
and this comes after remember
recently i think about a year ago
victoria's secrets chief marketing
officer
ed razek faced a ton of backlash for his
comments
about transgender models so this was his
quote
shouldn't uh shouldn't you have
transsexuals in the show
no no i don't think we should well why
not because the show is a fantasy
so he got away he's the owner of
victoria's secret
chief marketing officer oh i missed that
part and then that's when nicki dragon
did her fantasy video she was like this
isn't a fantasy and that video
was [ __ ] beautiful yeah nikita what
did i say
nikki oh my bad well i i'm just glad
that they're finally representing trans
people because they've been representing
people with wings for a long time
yep yeah like for too long
yeah angels you mean you don't like
angels yeah
okay well i wasn't into it i think this
is really dope but what about the ones
that were born female that turn into a
male
are they gonna represent them too well
that doesn't make sense because
victoria's secret is
only catered to women uh lingerie and
and bras and men do you wear a bra
tna bud do you feel do you feel left out
that we don't they don't market to you
no cause i thought they're trying to do
the whole equality thing so i thought it
was like okay so we're gonna folk but
they're only focusing on the after women
not the
before women bart's saying we're
stockings for like truckers and stuff
is that what you're saying no i'm just
talking about the whole their their
campaign they're trying to be equal
right
no no so they what they're saying here
is that they
have now okay previously
the the response the whole backlash for
the chief marketing officer this is what
he said
my remark regard regarding the inclusion
of transgender models in the victoria
secret fashion show came across as
insensitive i apologize
to be clear we absolutely would cast a
transgender model for the show
we've had transgender models come to
castings and like many others they
didn't make it but
it was never about gender i admire and
respect their journey to embrace who
they really are
it's because they weren't hot enough no
it's because yeah no it's because they
were talking about
when they when they asked them the
question i bet you anything this fool
imagine a bearded man in a [ __ ] tutu
that's what he imagined he just yeah
he's like there's no way i can have
these buff guys in my lingerie
yeah he's like we've had auditions for
them but they're just haven't been hot
enough yeah isn't that nice to hear
and then everyone's like disgusting and
they see this hot girl and they're he's
like
wait a minute i didn't know transgenders
can look this good
then he [ __ ] put him on that's what
happened so to be clear
his remarks were about the victoria's
secret fashion show
the valentina has been hired as a
victoria secret model
now they there have been rumors oh their
annual fashion show yes they're annual
that's a big theme so there have been
rumors that for this year
they will not be having let's see a
victoria's secret fashion show
and that's why i'm laughing stop pretty
much
because they are saying like the people
are laughing they're like oh that's
hilarious you
talk [ __ ] about transgenders um now
you're not gonna have a show
but hey good for you that now you've
hired one for your modeling what a bunch
of cynical [ __ ] he hired one
what the hell well i don't know if he
hired me oh well they hired one
yeah no yeah of course it's never enough
for the mob man the mom's always like
well we're still pissed because no so
the the
canceling of the show was first and now
after that is the hiring of valentina so
it's just how come they're cancelling
the show like couldn't make the wings in
time
they have a wing shortage yeah there's a
wing shortage
so they haven't even as far as i know
they haven't
fully confirmed that there won't be a
victoria's secret
show for 2019 but this rumor came about
because one of their models
was being interviewed and she said in an
interview that
she just feels really strange because
this time of the year is when she's
training hard
to be like an angel training but she
said that i
won't be she might not know maybe she
just didn't make the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] she just thinks like she's
oblivious she's like yeah didn't you
hear they're not doing it this year and
then the other chicks were like oh
we've been training 12 hours a day
that's like an nfl guys like yeah i
heard they cancel the nfl and they're
crazy
so this is what she said exact quote
unfortunately the victoria's secret show
won't be happening this year
it's something i'm not used to because
every year around this time i'm training
like an angel
but i'm sure in the future something
will happen which i'm pretty sure about
i'm sure they're trying to work on
branding and new ways to do the show
because it's the best show in the world
that's the direction i didn't even know
they had one every year dude they used
to it used to be big it used to be big
it used to be a ratings juggernaut but
but since porn's come out that [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ] anymore
it started in 1994 because i remember
back in the day
there was a big thing yeah and i didn't
know i didn't know they kept going dude
i remember it was on e and everyone was
like they would talk about it and [ __ ]
and now nobody cares at all
guys we're like get your [ __ ] tissues
ready yeah it's about to come out
dude it was even like that with catalogs
back then dude you get the victoria's
secret catalogue that was like the creme
de la creme yeah
that's better than uh what's the other
one jcpenney's catalog
absolutely i couldn't get that [ __ ] man
[ __ ] arizona jeans and [ __ ] yeah
dude [ __ ] macy's and jc penney's and
then you're looking at like mom bras and
you're like
what the [ __ ] i know you get mad because
you're like damn it dude why
why don't they use better models are
there uh victoria's secret like super
models
still do you know like so before it was
like you have gizelle bundchen you have
like
alessandra ambrosio tower banks like
people that are as like
big names now the ones are they they're
as big as are they just generic
kendall jenner's one yeah
yeah oh did you have dude's a victoria's
secret i don't think she's a victory
secret model she i think she
uh she starred in one but like they've
come out in the show
yeah or in the show but she didn't get
her rise in that
i think they're huge models first and
then they go oh so it's a different way
now instead of being
in the show and then coming up yeah she
was just like a special guest
because there used to be like stars yeah
i don't really hear like tyrone banks
i think we're past the super model like
era we could be
yeah i think because of instagram
there's just so many models now that
like back then like where did we see
like hot girls just like
magazines or search it online so
victoria's secret was like
actually like me and my whole family
would actually watch it like every year
like it was an outlet for models but now
models can make it on their own on
instagram did your dad watch it with the
blanket in his lap
no i did and the blanket was just
quivering up and down a little bit
and then you heard this noise there's no
knocking
no problem i was cracking my knuckles
stupid no none of that no cracking no
uh no no not that yeah no
not that i know creeps dude probably
they're probably because instagram and
all this stuff's so popular they're
gonna get that bella thorne now
to be a victoria's secret model oh yeah
what is uh what is the new
i forgot her name the uh valentina yeah
what is she how does she feel about
being one and and like being the first
and then
kind of what other people are saying
like oh like it's just a joke
because they're not even gonna have a
show uh no so people are
very supportive okay so half of it is
the guys that are out there they're just
like ew gross
yuck why would they do that they would
all [ __ ] that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are they talking about i'd
love to see their girlfriends yep
every guy who says that [ __ ] i want to
see a picture of your girlfriend yeah
but the
masses that i've seen the majority is
just that
people are really excited and they're
really happy that finally victoria
especially after what happened last year
like now they they
have evolved and they have finally
accepted someone
to be part of their their actual
modeling crew
but it's not necessarily because of the
whole show thing is just kind of like
oh you know we're not even going to see
a show but it's awesome that she gets to
model for them yeah she's still on print
and like advertisements right yeah
then yeah that's something that's
awesome forgive me for this question
because i'm a child
i know does this person still
have the dick or no oh man that was a
million dollar question i've been
thinking i always want to know
i don't know but maybe no because if if
she's like a
underwear model like how do you hide the
bulge
how do you hide it you could tuck it or
what if they
what if they're not even trying to hide
it if they did have it yeah that would
be interesting
what's your vote today if you'd rather
have my habit back and have it there or
not have it i don't know because
women's underwear you'd see the balls
hanging off the side
if it was a thong it's kind of hard you
got to wear like the
guy's banana hammock kind of style yeah
or there might be a question mark in the
front
maybe that's when they'll they'll
finally have a line to cater
to the men oh you want it i haven't
oh you know i just recently did read an
article that a
transgender woman she did create
the very first lingerie line for trans
transgender women who have not sniped
wow also has like the triangle flying
like a brief
imagine starting a business for 0.2
percent of the population
and then you're like we are open for
business and then you're like
okay i'm just waiting for sales they're
the owners
if they're the only no no we'll receive
this great i'm just talking about how
you know
who's your practicality like what's the
market what's that if it's the only
company
out there yeah they actually might they
might be the only business yeah there
you go but
once other competition comes out then
they're [ __ ] there's companies out
there that make
[ __ ] the most ridiculous thing that
no one would even
buy ever period but there's a company
out there that has it so
i don't think it's that far fetched well
there are some like very rare diseases
and [ __ ]
out there that the medication even stops
getting sold because there's nobody
buying it yeah
see yeah no that's that that's what i'm
saying
because it even was there in the first
place no but it was there but then they
took it up
but they're not a business tip you don't
get my seat yeah they made a mistake
they're like ah
bad idea i shouldn't have brought that
out last week well i
i'm pretty sure that this lingerie i
need to know what the population is
for transgender like because that is
right
with uh weiner still no yeah no that's
just transgender
it is transgender because transsexual is
one they've already
gone through the procedure i thought
they changed the word transsexual
because it's old and they don't like it
anymore
from what the last i looked into this
yeah can you update me because maybe i'm
not informed
transgender or they just like to be
after the surgery they just like to be
called whatever their surgery did
are people from transylvania kind of
pissed off because they're like they
used to be able to say i'm friends hey
we're trans
and then that's transylvania a real
place yeah okay you don't know dracula
it's in romania oh gosh
actually yeah yeah so transgender people
have a gender identity or gender
expression that differs from their
assigned sex
right some transgender people who desire
medical assistance to transition from
one sex to another
identify as transsexual bart social no
i'm still confused so post
op is transsexual yes and then pre-op is
it can be or it can it can be pre-op
post-op or whatever
it's just a transsexual is appropriate
now that's their identity i see okay
okay we're trying to get educated here
guys yeah i'm trying to learn because in
2017 transsexual was a bad word
no it wasn't it was it was was it yeah
well
people didn't like it they wanted they
wanted to be called
uh transgender well listen if you guys
think i'm incorrect don't blame me
playing google i just go
no i'm not saying you're incorrect i'm
glad that you're informing me because i
didn't know
i just want to know if transsexuals are
going to tell you if it's offensive to
the group or not
it's just gonna tell you the definition
of it can we see a picture of someone
from transylvania please
[Music]
you